they love Draconian policies they love
policies that will control you that have
nothing to do with science etc etc
here's what's going on in San Diego
right now we've got San Diego USD
President Sharon Whitehurst Payne uh
she's gonna mask up those kids because
apparently science parents who who don't
want to wear a mask indoors in school
are there any other options for them
for the fall there are some options they
can go to our school that's online
they can opt not to return to the
regular school but to go to the school
where they don't have to go to school at
all other than via zoom and that's the
easiest way for folks what about the
summer school what if they were already
enrolled in the summer school and now
they get this mask mandate and they're
not comfortable with wearing a mask
they really should wear the mask and if
they're not comfortable what should they
do
they should just let make it known that
they don't feel comfortable and at that
point just not return
all right look if you live in San San
Diego and you've got kids in that school
get your kids out you are a child abuser
if you're sending your kids to school to
have an unscientific piece of cloth
wrapped around their face that does
absolutely nothing we know that all the
masks except the n95s do nothing so if
you want to put your kid which and kids
have a 99.99999 survival rate on Cobin
and we're two and a half years past the
beginning of this freaking thing if you
want to wrap your kid in one of those
you're also a psycho but if you want to
do it I guess go ahead and then when
your kid takes you out early you know
when you're like 85 and they've got you
on the machine and your kid finally rips
their mask off and then they pull the
the life support from you you'll know
why but okay if you want to do that go
to town have fun
um but crazy you're crazy people who
live in California your Psychopaths
you're abusing your children and that
woman she has no expertise in anything
she's not a scientist masks do not work
kids are not getting sick it's up to
choices and of course what her
Alternatives oh we'll send you to zoom
school and we know that kids are getting
stupider they are literally getting
stupider kids are not speaking as early
as they should young toddlers we know
that the education level third graders
are now basically first graders fifth
graders or third graders like none of
this is working but if you people want
to be part of this go be part of it we
found an image of this woman Barbara
Barbara Federer she is the LA Department
she's the health lady in La I when I
lived in La I had a picture of this
woman in my bedroom and I would throw
darts at it at night just before I went
to bed she's the woman in charge of
locking down LA and putting the masks on
and everything else she's the one that
wants to bring the masks back can we get
her picture
so that's Barbara Ferrer is it fairer or
Federer or whatever her name is doesn't
matter doesn't matter what her name is
um and uh we found this other picture of
her because I knew I had seen her
sometime in the eight oh there she is
yes she actually also played the Evil
preacher in pollster in Poltergeist
remember that God is in his holy Temple
freaked me out as a kid freaked me out
but there she is again I'm not sure
which one's scarier to be quite there it
says we should have got Skeletor in the
mix too but if you want to take your
health advice from these people then
have at it if you want that woman on the
zoom call to lock your kids up in San
Diego have fun if you want Skeletor to
uh tell you to put a mask on in La have
at it there's nothing I can do for you
people at this point we tried